at this very second you are on a narrow
ledge between life and death
you probably don't feel it but there's
an incredible amount of activity going
on inside you
and this activity can never stop
picture yourself as a slinky falling
down an escalator moving upwards
the falling part represents the
self-replicating processes of your cells
the escalator represents the lords of
physics driving you forwards
to be alive is to be in motion but never
arriving anywhere
if you reach the top of the escalator
there's no more falling possible and you
are dead forever
somewhat unsettlingly the universe wants
you to reach the top
how do you avoid that and why are you
alive
[Music]
all life is based on the cell
a cell is a piece of the dead universe
that separated itself from the rest so
it could do its own thing for a while
when this separation breaks down it dies
and joins the rest of the dead universe
again
unfortunately the universe would like
for life to be done with doing its own
thing
for some reason it's not a fan of
exciting things but tries to be as
boring as possible
we call this principle entropy and it's
a fundamental rule of our universe
it's pretty complicated and
counter-intuitive so we'll explain it in
detail in another video
for now all you need to know is living
things are inherently exciting
a cell is filled up with millions of
proteins and millions more simpler
molecules like water
thousands of complex self-replicating
processes are happening up to hundreds
of thousands of times every second
to stay alive and exciting it has to
constantly work to keep itself from
achieving entropy and becoming boring
and debt
the cell has to maintain the separation
from the rest of the universe
it's doing this for example by keeping
the concentration of certain molecules
different on the inside and the outside
by actively pumping out excess molecules
to do stuff like this a cell needs
energy
energy is the ability of things in the
universe to do work to move or
manipulate a thing to create change
this ability cannot be created or
destroyed the set amount of energy in
the universe will never change we don't
know why it just is that way
so billions of years ago one of the most
crucial challenges for the first living
beings was to get usable energy
we don't know a lot about the first
cells except that they got their energy
from simple chemical reactions
and they found the ultimate energy
transfer system
the energetic building block of life
the molecule adenosine triphosphate
or atp
its structure makes it uniquely good at
accepting and releasing energy
when a cell needs energy for example to
pump out molecules or to repair a broken
micro machine it can break down atp and
use the chemical energy to do work and
create change
this is why living beings are able to do
stuff
we don't know when or how exactly the
first atp molecule was made on earth
but every living thing we know uses atp
or something very similar to keep its
internal machinery running
it's crucial for almost every process
plants fungi bacteria and animals need
to survive
without atp no life on earth possibly
anywhere
while breaking down chemicals for energy
is nice and all early life did miss out
on the greatest available source of
energy the sun
the sun merges atoms and radiates
photons away that carry energy into the
solar system
but this energy is raw and indigestible
it needs to be refined
after hundreds of millions of years of
evolution finally a cell figured out how
to eat the sun
it absorbed radiation and converted much
of it into neat little chemical packages
that it could use to stay alive
we call this process photosynthesis
you take photons that are wobbly with
electromagnetic energy and use a part of
this energy to merge and combine
different molecules together
the electromagnetic energy is converted
into chemical energy stored in the atp
molecule
this process became even better as some
cells learned to create better chemical
packages
glucose or sugar
easy to break down high in energy and
pretty tasty
this is so convenient that some cells
decided that instead of doing all that
pesky photosynthesis work themselves
they would just swallow other cells that
did and take their glucose and atp
this is widely considered one of the
biggest anime betrayals in evolutionary
history
and so things went on
photosynthesizing cells could mostly
harness energy at their surfaces which
limited their maximum energy production
which limited their evolutionary avenues
somewhat
so time passed
some cells made sugar others ate them
evolution did its thing but overall
things stayed pretty much the same for
hundreds of millions of years
until one day
a cell ate another and did not kill it
instead
they became one cell
nothing had changed that day but earth
would be different forever
this cell became the ancestor of all
animals on this planet
blue whales amoeba dinosaurs jellyfish
pink fairy armadillos and sunder kalugos
and of course you
all can trace back their existence to
this moment
the merging of two living beings is so
important because when those two cells
became one they became way more powerful
the formerly independent cell in the
inside could stop trying to survive
it could concentrate on one thing make
atp
it became the powerhouse of the cell the
first mitochondria
the host cell's job became to ensure
survival in the dangerous world and
provide the mitochondria with food
mitochondria basically reverse
photosynthesis in a similarly complex
process
they take sugar molecules that we got
from eating other living things combust
them with oxygen and precursor molecules
to make new energy rich atp molecules
this process works like a tiny furnace
and spits out waste products like co2
water and a little bit of kinetic energy
that you experience as body heat
this first division of labor meant the
new cell had way more energy available
than any cell before which meant more
possibilities for evolution to enable
more complex cells
at some point these cells began to form
small groups or communities
which led to multicellular life and
finally to you
today
you are a pile of trillions of cells
each filled with dozens if not hundreds
of little machines that provide you with
usable energy to stay alive
if this process is interrupted even for
a few minutes you die
but if life is so fragile wouldn't it be
a good idea to store atp
like we store sugar in our fat cells so
we don't die if we stop breathing for a
while
if life has solved so many problems to
make you live today what's up with the
dying quickly thing
even simple bacteria like e coli make
about 50 times their body weight in atp
for every cell division
your trillions of cells need a lot of
atp to keep you around
every day your body produces and
converts about 90 million billion
billion molecules of atp
about your own body weight
you need a whole person's worth of atp
just to make it through a single day
even storing enough atp to last you a
few minutes is basically impossible
an atp molecule is really good for
shifting energy around quickly but it's
terrible for storage since it has only
one percent of the glucose molecules
energy at three times its mass
so atp is constantly produced and used
up fairly quickly
this was the short and simplified story
of the molecule that allows you to be
different from the dead universe and to
be the slinky on the escalator it is a
weird story
there is this molecule you need to
survive at all times
you need it to keep moving because even
a short break brings your slinky to a
stop
and you need to make it yourself
it's like driving a car at full speed
while producing fuel in the trunk with
junk that you pick up from the side of
the road
as far as we know this all began
billions of years ago when tiny parts of
the dead universe came together and
became something else for a moment
it could keep itself going
it could grow
that moment set the slinky in motion and
it's been going ever since
from the very first cells to you
watching this now
at some point you will merge with the
rest of the dead universe again maybe
you'll tell its stories about your
adventures maybe not
but before you find out you get to do
what life does best
making a dead universe
much more interesting
if you are currently bored for whatever
reason and you want to make your life
more interesting we've got something for
you
we partnered with skillshare an online
learning community that offers thousands
of classes for all skill levels on tons
of creative skills like illustration
animation cooking creative writing or
film and video
learning something while creating stuff
for yourself is pretty fun and
fulfilling
if you want to learn animation we made a
few skillshare classes where we
explained how we animated scenes from
our videos with video lessons and
hands-on projects
you can get unlimited access to all
classes for less than ten dollars a
month with an annual premium membership
and the first one thousand quarts quest
viewers to click the link in the
description will get a two-month free
trial
and if you're just getting started for
beginners who want to dip a toe into
illustrations similar to ours we
recommend vector illustration using
creative constraints to find your style
by rick berkelmann
just try something to improve your
skills and at the same time fight the
boredom of being stuck inside
if you want to get creative with new
skills and support kotskazak give it a
try
[Music]
you